hablemos un poco acerca de los grupos de
la tabla periódica una manera muy
sencilla de hablar de los grupos es que
solo son las columnas de la tabla
periódica y la convención estándar es
numerar las esta es la primera columna
es el grupo 1 segunda columna tercer
grupo cuarto quinto sexto séptimo octavo
grupo nueve grupo 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 y 18 y también algunos de ustedes
podrían estar pensando qué sucede con
estos elementos del bloque efe de aquí
si hiciéramos la tabla periódica de
manera apropiada no veríamos todo esto
todo lo del bloque de y bloque de al
lado derecho y haríamos espacio para
estos elementos del bloque efe pero la
convención es que no los numerados pero
que es lo interesante aquí porque nos
tomamos la molestia de llamar a estas
columnas grupos esto es lo interesante
de la tabla periódica es que todos los
elementos en una columna para la mayor
parte y hay un montón de excepciones
casi todos los elementos en una columna
tienen propiedades muy similares y eso
es porque los elementos en una columna o
grupo tienden a tener el mismo número de
electrones en su orbital más alejado
tienden a tener el mismo número de
electrones de valencia los cuales son
los electrones en el orbital más alejado
los electrones de valencia son los
electrones que van a reaccionar y como
ya mencioné son los electrones más
alejados pero hay excepciones a eso y
sobre todo hay muchas excepciones
interesantes que pasan en los metales de
transición en el bloque p pero no
entraré en esos detalles sólo pensemos
un poco en algunos de los grupos que
podrías escuchar y de porqué reaccionan
en maneras muy similares si vamos al
grupo 1 el hidrógeno tiene un
comportamiento bastante extraño porque
el hidrógeno no intenta obtener los 8
electrones de valencia el hidrógeno en
ese primer orbital solo quiere llegar a
2 electrones de valencia como los tiene
el helio y entonces el hidrógeno no es
no comparte tanto con todos los demás
elementos en el grupo 1 como podrías
decir de todos los elementos en el grupo
2 en el grupo 1 si pones al hidrógeno de
un lado a esto se les conoce como
metales alcalinos y el hidrógeno no se
considera un metal alcalino estos de
aquí son los me
les
nos ahora porque todos estos reaccionan
de manera muy similar porque tienen
propiedades tan parecidas para pensar en
ello debes de pensar en su configuración
electrónica
por ejemplo la configuración electrónica
para el litio será la misma que la
configuración electrónica de él
el lío
y luego continuará con su segundo
orbital 2s 1
tiene un electrón de valencia tiene un
electrón en su orbital más alejado que
pasa con el sodio el sodio tendrá la
misma configuración electrónica que el
cne
y luego continuará con 3s 1
nuevamente tiene un electrón de valencia
un electrón en su orbital más alejado
todos estos elementos se naranja aquí
tienen un electrón de valencia e
intentan llegar a la regla del octeto
que es una especie de nirvana estable
para los átomos y entonces puedes
imaginar que son muy reactivos y una vez
que reaccionan tienden a perder ese
electrón en su orbital más alejado y ese
es el caso estos metales alcalinos son
muy muy reactivos y tienen propiedades
muy similares son brillantes y suaves y
de hecho debido a que son tan reactivos
es difícil encontrarlos donde no han
reaccionado con otros elementos sigamos
viendo los otros grupos si nos movemos
uno a la derecha
este grupo de aquí estos son conocidos
como los metales alcalinos terios
me da 10
acá
knopf
y nuevamente tienen propiedades muy
similares y eso es porque tienen dos
electrones de valencia dos electrones en
su orbital más alejado y también para
ellos no son tan reactivos como los
metales alcalinos pero para ellos es más
fácil perder dos electrones que intentar
ganar seis para llegar a ocho y entonces
estos tienden a ser razonablemente
reactivos y reaccionan perdiendo esos
dos electrones más alejados ahora algo
interesante sucede mientras te vas al
bloque de y estudiamos esto cuando vimos
configuraciones electrónicas pero si ves
la configuración electrónica para
digamos el cambio de aquí haré eso en
magenta la configuración electrónica
para el escandio
es cambió la configuración electrónica
para el escandio será la misma que la
del argón y luego la llenarás como si
estuvieras en el periodo 1 2 3 4 será 4
s 2
y luego comenzaremos a llenar el bloque
de estos son los elementos del bloque de
y tienes que recordar que en el bloque
de llenas de hadas adelante por lo que
en el bloque de esto será ahora tres de
uno cuántos electrones tiene en su
orbital más alejado nuevamente su
orbital más alejado es su cuarto orbital
estos son tus electrones del nivel más
alto como sabes estos se llenan antes
que éstos y hay excepciones para esto
especialmente vemos muchas en el bloque
de pero estos creo puedes decir que en
cierto grado están definiendo su
reactividad estos los electrones más
alejados aún se tienen dos de los
electrones más alejados y nuevamente
estas son excepciones en estos metales
de transición pero la mayor parte del
tiempo llenan desde atrás ese bloque de
y después de llenar esos bloques de por
atrás
vienes acá y comienzas a llenar el
bloque pe por ejemplo si ves la
configuración electrónica para digamos
el carbono el carbono tendrá la misma
configuración electrónica que él
y luego llenará su bloque s 2 s 2 y
luego 2 1 2 2 p 2 y cuantos electrones
de valencia tiene bueno en su orbital
más alejado tiene 2 más 2 tiene cuatro
electrones de valencia y eso será cierto
para los elementos en este grupo
y debido a eso el carbono tiene un
comportamiento de enlace similar al
silicio y también a los demás elementos
en su grupo podemos continuar por
ejemplo con el oxígeno y el azufre
estos dos querrán tomar dos electrones
de alguien más porque tienen 6
electrones de valencia quieren llegar a
8 así que tienen un comportamiento de
enlace similar vamos a este grupo
amarillo de aquí
estos son los halógenos hay un nombre
especial para ellos
estos son los
lo
y estos son altamente reactivos porque
tienen 7 electrones de valencia no hay
algo que deseen más que tener un
electrón de valencia más
ellos aman reaccionar de hecho a ellos
especialmente les gusta reaccionar con
los metales alcalinos de aquí y luego
finalmente llegas a una especie de
turbana atómico en los gases nobles aquí
y los gases nobles es otro nombre para
el grupo 18 de elementos ya se es
no hables
y todos tienen la propiedad muy similar
de no ser reactivos
y por qué no reaccionan porque tienen 8
electrones de valencia han llenado su
orbital más alejado no encuentran la
necesidad son nobles están como arriba
de los demás no tienen la necesidad de
reaccionar con nadie más